Pluto: Planet or not? Before we answer this question to us
To know what the word planet means and this brings us back to the ancient Greeks who were called on
Mercury, Venus, Mars, Jupiter, Saturn Moon and Sun Planet Name. If the body moves
In the sky and shines, it is a planet. This is not a good meaning of the word
First, because it does not include the Earth and secondly, this description combines quite different objects.
But the Greeks could not understand the difference between the sun and Saturn, because
The technology they relied upon to observe the universe was unfortunately limited.
It took thousands of years for the Dutch to make the first telescope
Astronomy became interesting. Astronomers can rearrange
The solar system with complete confidence - a scientific breakthrough that no one can object to
It - and re-classification of its components, exclude the sun and moon from the list of planets
Hosts the planet. Now, what is going on around the sun, it is a planet.
As time passed, the telescopes improved and each century came
To discover a new planet. Which brought us to our solar system as we know it today:
Nine planets revolve around one star. Looking at this model makes people wonder
Why astronomers want to exclude Pluto? The problem is that such images are in textbooks
liar. Well, not false but unrealistic. It gives us the illusion that the planets
They are of equal size and distance to some extent, but in fact, it is very different.
This, dear planet, our planet and this planet Jupiter is next to it in size
Correct - looks bigger than I expected. If we take this fee and adjust it by
The correct sizes for all the planets will look like this. Unless you see this offer
Clearly and on a full screen, you may not even be able to see Pluto.
If the difference in the planetary sizes is vast, Pluto is the youngest. But it is not only the smallest planet
But smaller than seven satellites: Triton, Europe, Comarna, Ayo, Calisto
Titan, and Ganemide. Even if you will display the correct sizes
The distance is still a problem. Think about it, if Jupiter is near this earth
It will not appear as a point in the night sky but it will be much larger - if
It has to be far, which is a challenge if we want to draw it in the right size. if you want
To use white paper to represent the distance starting with Mercury and ending with Pluto, the buyer
The giant may appear as large as dust mites on this paper, but Pluto, the size of bacteria.
But excluding Pluto from the constellation of planets being far and small is not a sufficient reason
And soon the fury of Pluto's defenders is aroused. In order for us to truly understand Pluto,
We have to talk about a planet you've never heard of: Ceres.
In 1801, astronomers discovered a new planet in the vast space between Mars and Jupiter
- He was a small planet, but they loved him and called him Ceres.
The following year, scientists discovered another small planet in the same area called Palas.
A few years later, they discovered third planet Juno, then, fourthly,
Vista. For several years, schoolchildren have studied eleven planets in the solar system.
But astronomers have discovered more and more of these objects and become uncomfortable
Launching the name of a planet on them because they were more like each other than they were like planets
Other, a new category was added: asteroids in the asteroid belt - and the small planets were subjected
To renaming, and for this reason you did not hear them. This was a correct decision
Astronomers have discovered hundreds of thousands of asteroids that could have made a child difficult
If they are all classified as planets. Back to Pluto. It was discovered in 1930
It became the ninth planet. Preliminary estimates show the size of Pluto as the size of Neptune, but after many observations
His size began to diminish. As Pluto dwindled, astronomers began
Searching for other objects in the same area.
Does it seem familiar? While school children kept the names of the planets
Nine, some astronomers felt uncomfortable about adding Pluto to the planets because of its size
They continued to fade, because they learned that Pluto was made up of ice, and they continued to
Find lots and lots of glaciers at the edge of the Pluto-like solar system.
This problem could have been ignored as long as no one found a glacier than Pluto
What exactly happened in 2006 with the discovery of Iris. Again, the astronomers returned
The arrangement of the solar system and the collection of these objects distant, in addition to Pluto, in
A new area called the Kapper Belt. This is the story of Pluto - the lost planet
Who returned to where he finally belonged - like Siris. But this story does not talk about
Pluto only, but she talks about why the word 'planet' is inaccurate.
The first four planets in the solar system are very different from the four planets that follow
The classification of these eight under one group is a bit strange and that is why they are separated from and divided
To the rocky planets and gaseous giants. And now we have telescopes
Through which we can see planets revolving around other stars, and we have discovered rogue planets roaming the space
And pygmy brown - the blurring of the difference between the planet and the star - word
The planet becomes less clear. So, the more you know the universe
The 'planets' species may continue to evolve, or may fall and disappear
Completely. But, for now, the best way to classify
The objects in our solar system are to one star, eight planets, four rocky, four
Gas giants, the asteroid belt, and the distant Kiper belt, to which Pluto belongs.